hi I'm Hannah and today I'm letting my
kids design my makeup look if I wear
makeup at all I usually spend about ten
minutes on it
it's mascara it's blush and it's
lipstick and that's it I have let the
boys do you mind makeup every day for an
entire week and it was terrible I love
them but they make terrible makeup
artist this is my homecoming luck spent
a lot worse than I thought it would so I
don't have high hopes I think if I go in
with very low expectations I'll be
pleasantly surprised let's check in with
boys and see what they're expecting for
today what's your name what's your name
do you know much about makeup caked up
and what's your favorite part of makeup
okay so do you guys know why you're here
to put makeup on me you're gonna design
my makeup left okay who is this this is
where you guys are gonna color the
makeup and I'm not gonna be able to see
and so at the end I'm gonna be surprised
with it what colors do you think you're
going to use what okay what are their
colors do they match my hair excellent
do you know where to put makeup oh I
know where does mascara go yeah
eyelashes
where does blush go okay can you guys
remember that please yeah okay hey you
promised me pinky promise I have a
feeling they're gonna try to color every
part of my things because that's kind of
how they color their coloring books and
I think that might be how they treat
this my name is Justine I've been doing
makeup for about six years when I talk
to the kids about what they should draw
I will give them enough rules that they
won't just scribble on the paper but I
don't want to give them too many rules
that they can't be creative with this
alright are you ready to do this yeah
we're gonna design your mom's makeup on
this piece of
we're okay oh you want to write I was
really big
oh that's cool
it kind of almost looks like a clown I
won't want to affect what other things
do clowns use with their makeup cool
nice
thanos green pea I can't color her teeth
you want her to have a gray mustache and
a boom oh that's so silly that's very
creative you're gonna make my job hard
now on that module it's so pretty
hi Steve Anna how are you I'm alone
already
hahaha but your makeup looks really
great so I'm excited
well the boys did not designed my makeup
but they were so cute they had so much
fun coloring it I'm really excited for
you to see it I have the picture over
here so don't look over I see lots of
colors you might just have like a little
stain on your skin from all the crazy
colors noted sometimes my kids are very
nice and sometimes they'll be like I
want to shave you all of your hair off
and your eyebrows they're so creative
[Laughter]
what is happening I'm just gonna keep
telling myself this is all foundation
she's just gonna blend it Oh God
you did say that clowns were part of
their in this bridge you know it kind of
cool
don't put anything there no this is
really fun I'm having fun I'm going to
be working on your upper lip but they
called it your mustache all right I
think I'm done I feel like I have a
clown face I know there's some weird
design in the center of my forehead
there's some sort of mustache and some
sort of beard
you look like an art piece abstract yeah
it's really cool I like it would you
post this on your Instagram yes
what I post this on my Instagram yeah
you pull it off all right we're gonna
bring the blaze in and show them I hope
they like it
me
[Music]
beautiful did you do beautiful work do
you think I'm gonna like it yeah yeah I
heard you gave me a mustache today see
accent Oh Jackson he called you do I
look like a clown no you guys think it
looks like your drawing yeah yeah what
do I look like you look like your own
self
that's maybe nice maybe not I don't know
yet so this is the picture that you guys
drew oh my god it looks good on you it
doesn't go down the page okay
hmm this does not give me hope yeah oh
my goodness I thought this might have
been a full lie you guys really went for
it with the colors I'm like no you like
my yellow nose
yeah do you think she did a good job on
my face yeah she did a good job of my
face
how about my face yeah that's the
goodest I'm Lola I do look like an
abstract piece of art and kind of like
puddle of water and you're not mixed
with old man with my OTN mustache do you
think you didn't sir Graham it yeah you
know everybody would love it everybody
would love that so I had to walk out in
the office like this oh my gosh
did you do this you're a liar
your sister you look like an abstract
art do you think babies yes that is so
cute you think clown is that what it's
supposed to be do you have any yeah
would you take me seriously I totally
would thank God did you have fun I think
I'm the only one who could do without
doing this again I think next time it's
gonna be me doing your makeup no next
deal it's gonna be a need new your ring
you've already done it
this was a one and done kind of thing
this is funny and now I want to go take
[Music]